abricot emergency aux finales nationales
conson le directeur général de l'om et
sa tranchée la variole simienne est
désormais une urgence de santé publique
à portée internationale
une maladie grave qui garde encore tous
ses mystères
outbreaks l'épidémie s'est propagée
rapidement dans le monde entier par de
nouveaux modes de transmission dans
l'eau et metz ne sait pas grand chose
plus de 6000 cas ont été répertoriés
dans 75 pays faisant cinq morts
l'épicentre de la maladie se situe en
europe une étude récente parue dans le
new england journal of medicine nous
apprend que 98 % des malades sont
homosexuelles ou bisexuelles et que la
transmission sexuelle a été soupçonné
dans 95 % des cas le docteur réjean
thomas et à collaborer et de par sa
pratique quotidienne ils appellent à
l'action ce qui m'inquiète pas bénigne
tant que ça contrairement à ce qu'on a
dit au début et il faut essayer de
stopper cette épidémie la plus
rapidement possible la vaccination
demeure le meilleur moyen de freiner la
propagation en essence ou d'avoir un
maximum en même temps le nombre de
vaccins illimité pour le moment on
vaccine les personnes d'une seule joie
on a peu déteint sur l'efficacité c'est
back the lights et j'espère que le
comité d'immunisation du québec va
revoir sa politique parce qu'ils ne
recommandent pas de vacciner les
personnes qui travaillent ou qui font le
dépistage déplacer avec la baby gym
yonne alors que les infirmiers et les
infirmières sont rares mais qui est un
appel à l'action face à la
multiplication des cas au canada qui
compte 680 et une infection dont près de
la moitié au québec ici acheminera ya
traduit au canada montréal